all right megan
hi welcome back how are you so nice to
see you again
so it was about six months ago that you
and i first met we did that
that interview which was great i love
it's one of my favorites
um but lots has happened since then
right yes i had a major turnaround
i um had a relapse let me explain what
happened so
we did that first interview and you and
i
kind of i just saw so much potential in
you and i
uh i got you a car right um two two cars
right
two the first one to be precise the
first first one didn't work out so i got
you a second car but
um and then i paid for some like
housing and some other stuff like that
because i saw you like
you're doing the right thing you were
getting a job you were you're no longer
on fig
all kinds of great things were happening
and i love to help people who are trying
to straighten their lives out
but i can't do that forever and ever and
and also things kind of you had some
setbacks as well right
yeah so major setbacks um
okay so right after you got me the truck
i seen a car
you know i came the first thing i said
was mark i seen this bmw and i really
like it
i really really like it he's like okay
i'm gonna help you this time i want to
see you do right i said okay mark i got
you don't trip i'm gonna do right by you
i get this car and i'm like [ __ ] i'm
free bowling cause i got the bmw now i'm
feeling big in life like oh
i got me a two-door beer bmw yeah it was
used but you know it was still something
somebody did something for me you you
went out of your way to do something
that nobody else has done for me
and i kind of took advantage of it i
took that ball and rolled with it even
when the ball got flat
and it wasn't such a good thing because
messing around with that car got me back
up at the edge of town
by ivy and when i started hanging out
with ivy
things kind of go backwards for me i
started using them drugs again
and kind of fell off don't blame my
viewers
no not because of ivy but you know that
it deals with
a lot of it is in her circle of people i
just think it's important to take
responsibility for everything that
happens in your life and you know
that that not even i can't even say peer
pressure because it's not peer pressure
it's kind of just like hey you want to
hit this it was
like i'm in the moment i got a little
bit of money
okay yeah i'm gonna hit it and then i
hit it and i wound up
turning all the way around i lost my car
and then i winded up losing my funding
mark left me for my lonesome he said
today you gonna learn today
and i learned i did learn um that's
probably the biggest mistake i think i
made within our time knowing each other
was turning around and doing the
opposite of what i was supposed to do
because it kind of put me back at phase
one
starting to have to get my kids all over
again my health
the housing situation really got bad i
mean
you even help with the the housing we
paid for the weekly 490 for a weekly
and somehow someway i found myself being
lazy not wanting to get up and go
do the job that i was assigned for wind
up losing the job
and then i turned back around like hey
mark i need another car
my car's broken like
uh this car broke i need another car and
that was like
when you first first started getting the
the black girls heavy and the nova and
jasmine started coming around and they
started saying i got these other girls
and i got these other girls
and everybody's doing the nitpick and
they're like megan let me borrow some
money
i screwed up i said jasmine i'll borrow
i'll let you brought the money
then i kind of put myself in the hole
helping everybody else with what mark
helped me with
because well mark helped me with i'd
even have to be giving away in the first
place
yeah i gave away the help that i was
given and kind of screwed myself over
wind up sleeping inside the same truck
you bought me i want those sleeping
inside the back seat
out of trading my truck in for another
car because everything just started
going sideways i guess when you don't
money manage the right way and you're
not um
stable in your head you turn around and
you relapse
you know you don't think straight you
don't think
normal like a normal human okay let me
put my money up for this payment or for
that it was just kind of like okay i got
the car
i got the money let's just go have fun
yeah what i've seen with a lot of people
that i've helped
is and you didn't do this but i've seen
i've seen this with a lot of people who
kind of assumed oh this is my new sugar
daddy
and this is now my he's my at he's my
atm machine
and then if i if i start to pull back on
that support they they get angry
you know what and you didn't do that but
but you did probably i didn't get angry
it did hurt me a little bit
that you stopped helping me but that was
nobody's fault of my own
because it it's kind of true not saying
that
i was looking at you like a trick but
when we have good friends and we don't
realize what type of good friends that
we have and we're on drugs or we're out
here and we're working the streets and
stuff
we kind of tend to forget where our
loyalty lies
and we turn around and say hey because
he gave me money one time he'll do it
again yeah
then we start getting in that phase of
acting like as if he's treated me like a
trick or something
yeah like it felt and then you know when
you really consider somebody a friend
and they're really really helping you
and you take that step back and
re-analyze the situation
and you look at it like okay now i'm
starting to affect myself
and this is a real good friend that i
have and these friends are hard to come
by you don't get a friend that's going
to be like oh yeah here's 1200
you know you don't find that at all
shoot i can't barely get somebody give
me five dollars let alone 1200
and to have that to turn around and [ __ ]
it up like that
i kind of beat myself up afterwards i
didn't go lie to you
i was beating myself up like man i just
lost a good ass friend
[ __ ] around trying to be cool trying
to hang out trying to smoke drugs
i lost the the financial support and i
really needed it at the time you know
especially with the housing situation
and the pandemic
all this happening at one time with my
kids and their health
it kind of like i felt [ __ ] up i felt
like damn i am treating him like a trick
i'm treating him like how every other
girl from the streets would treat him
like every other prostitute like okay
he's just a [ __ ] trick
but it was like never intentionally like
that
but at the same time when you live the
life it's kind of like
okay here's this guy he's helping with
the money cool it's just like kind of
you kind of fall into these categories
even if we don't mean to slide you into
that category
you kind of just slide into the category
because why that's what we're used to
yeah that's that's how
we're used to getting up going out
finding these nice guys with nice
pockets and they nicely become our
friends
so me not thinking and saying hey i got
a good friend here
i've seen it happen that's willing to
keep pushing with me
and keep telling me that i can instead
of i can't and i'm i'm a piece of [ __ ]
and i can't get nowhere in life
it's like hey i know you could do it do
better and you're
constantly here here here we take
advantage of it and i caught myself
taking advantage of and had to
say you know let me just stop calling
her for a little bit let me let me not
call mark today
i got everybody on my back oh call mark
call mark call mark everybody call mark
i'm like i'm not calling mark for you
guys i'm not even calling mark for
myself
they i did pick up that phone and said
mark i need i got the hell no ain't
happening today
look i gave you too much money making
it's not happening no more click
i said and he hung up in my face oh
i got to cry and i watered up a little
bit like tear hold on
[ __ ] mark just hang up on me i called
back like five times on facetime like
mark hung up i can be a cold-hearted
bastard sometimes yes you were being a
cold-hearted bastard that day and i was
like this [ __ ] right here got me
so twisted if you don't answer this
[ __ ] phone i got to call him
but i have to do that because i get so
many people yeah you know it's messed up
because
i'm like this [ __ ] just hung up
in my face he said he ain't helping me
no more
and then i had to think about like damn
[ __ ] you're the one that told him to do
that
you like literally physically sat there
a couple days ago and told him mark if
you don't start saying no to people
and start telling these [ __ ] like
[ __ ] i ain't gonna give you no more
money
you're gonna be broke i turn around i
get to be the first one to get that cold
harder to know like oh
[ __ ] but when i when you when i was
helping you i was helping you freely
right yeah you were helping me freely
it'd be like hey
you need something for today whatever
you need you know let me know because
you're trying
yeah the day that i stopped trying and
and you were working you got a job i
forget where but
um i was doing i was doing security and
construction because i remember
people already yeah um you were you were
working hard
you were doing it busting my ass yeah to
try to do better just to turn around
no i still believe in you but but it you
know it's just
so tell me what's going on today now you
are today hold on hold on let's talk
about what happened this week
this week yes it's hard to believe
because you look so great i had a
life-changing experience
when i say life's changes before you
tell people
look how beautiful megan looks you look
healthier and happier than ever right
i'm healthy and i'm fat
getting chunky you look awesome i look a
lot better
a lot bigger than i did when i had that
blue dress on last time we did the
interview
oh yeah i've got a couple like maybe you
know you got cheeks in there you didn't
look too scared you didn't look too
skinny to me
i felt skinny i feel a lot better about
myself now
that the drug use has been to a minimal
but then again i had that life-changing
experience where it was like
reality came up and smacked me right in
my face like hey look you having a heart
attack and you're 25.
yes you had a heart attack this week
yeah so this week i experienced my
first phase of being old at a very young
age
i had a heart attack you're 25 25 years
old
and having a heart attack in the
hospital for a week with blood pressure
pills
i mean i was getting poached but they
were coming in every two hours
taking at least six to seven tubes of
blood just to figure out what was wrong
with me
come to find out i smoked a blonde with
the wrong person somebody put
fentanyl i don't know it's some new
morphine or something that they the
doctors got
um and the people are using it actually
for the drug addicts they're
putting it out there to kind of knock
them off kind of like a population
control through the government without
being
like that's what it seems like there's
different ways of seeing it fentanyl is
a dangerous drug
it's very dangerous so when they told me
it's a morphine i'm looking like hold on
you're sitting here telling me the same
thing that just almost killed me
is the same thing you're distributing
it's a morphe
and you're gonna give it to us and these
people are gonna dumbly freely take it
if i hadn't known that there was
fentanyl in the blood i wouldn't have
smoked it
but my my heart swelled up like as big
as my hand
like not my fist open hand like my heart
was
big and they said it was [ __ ] for two
three weeks i was coughing up packing up
yellow stuff like what's wrong with me i
can't breathe
i'm having trouble in taking anything i
couldn't eat
couldn't sleep and when i finally went
to sleep i laid down
well i sleep in a fetal position i sleep
like a baby so i lay down in the fetal
position and i
see myself get up i'm like okay i'm
gonna go to the bathroom
except for i forgot something i turned
around i said oh my god
oh my god jesus lord have mercy on my
soul i'm sorry whatever i did please
help me take it back i will take
everything back i will change my life
for good
i turned around and i see me in the bed
i said oh my god
oh my god i'm not in my body what is
wrong with this it's like a completely
different type of life experience
i do i double took i said oh jesus
i'm not what the hell is going on i had
to tell myself to lay back down
i had that out of body experience where
it's like look this was about to happen
if you don't
correct it i went to that hospital
they put me in that bed for a week and
tomorrow i actually go to
a 90-day program to get better for my
daughters
they'll be placing my daughters with me
in the program
um it feels like an awesome thing being
without my kids for this long has made
me feel so empty and alone
i kind of feel dead i'm not gonna sit
here and lie
people think that oh you don't have your
kids go have fun
experience life no there's no experience
without them once you have your kids
you have your kids and that's like a
major part of you
like i wake up looking for that little
crash and that boom and bang like so i
turn around like say you're gracious
what did you just break and there's no
say or gracious just ask
what did you just break to it's it's the
loneliness
after a while the drugs doesn't matter
anymore
it went from fun to bland to black to
i ain't even fit to do that [ __ ] no more
because i'm losing everything i got i
don't lost my car
i'd have lost my house i don't lost my
kids i've lost
all my friends none of my family will
talk to me that i do still have in
existence
and i was damn near closely losing you
mark
very very very close probably close to
losing your life maybe
and then almost lost my life at 25 years
old i'm laying in the bed
stroking out having a heart attack and
that was not fun that was the worst
experience i think i've ever had and to
think
like damn just for a drug i'm willing
i'm laying here and i'm willing
to exit my children's life for good and
to have them wonder and ask all the same
questions that i wondered and asked when
i was growing up
it's not a good feeling and we're sam
i tell people all the time they say so
what is your relationship with your kids
so we're sam sayora aurora and megan we
make sam
we're together we're the is together
they eat with me they sleep with me they
shower with me they go to work with me
not having that and doing so many drugs
it's like okay
your mind gets fogged and now that my
mind's not fogging i got that slap in
the face by reality it's like i gotta
pick up
where i left off with mark the first
time i got to get back on my feet got to
get back on that straight path and and
ride that highway all the way through
all the way to the pretty little light
at the end
and knowing that now
and being able to talk to my daughters
the other day was kind of like
wow what the hell's wrong with you megan
you've got two beautiful little girls
and you out here thugging with the
homies like
you a [ __ ] i'm not a [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm out
here selling drugs like i'm a [ __ ]
smoking dope smart powder like i'm a
homie
it's not cute and then my daughters i
didn't think about it like my daughter
see a lot of stuff that i do
and what made me really think was my
daughter said what'd you say
heffa i said huh hold on did what'd you
just call me she said heffa
i said this little baby just called me a
heifer we got an issue little baby
why you call me a headphone she said
what you say
i said okay so i see where this is going
i see that they're following
everything mommy does mommy says heffa
you gonna say hessel
i say what you say she turned around
with the figure what you say
he said well say say mommy said well no
no
don't talk to me and don't talk to my
baby i said oh no my kid thinks she's
grown
and i see where i'm now i'm starting to
see the same thing that happened with my
mom
within myself and i don't want to see
that at all because
now my mom is a heroin user she
constantly tells me when i do talk to
her i'm sick
help me give me some medicine i'm sick
hey keeps i'm laughing and spending 50
on some [ __ ] heroin so you go get
high what's that look like
but then i have to re-analyze myself
like damn i just told you i'm about to
go spend 50
on your high but i turn around and spend
50 on my high
i don't even want to get high no more
that slap in the face where reality even
now
i don't take my medication on time with
this past week they've given me my blood
pressure my heart medicine
if i don't take that medicine on time
i'm like i'm about to fall out about the
dye i need some water somebody help me
somebody read this for me i get to see
in 3us
and i don't want to have to go through
that and i don't want to lose my life at
such a young age
at all and i think my daughters need me
because the dad's not doing so well
either of course last time we talked
about their dad being a pimp um
come to find out um this week
while i was in the hospital he went to
jail for stealing a car
and spouse abused breaking some girl's
rib that he said ain't no [ __ ]
ain't no [ __ ] you don't love me you
moved on ain't no [ __ ] why you doing
why you do me like this said i did you
last time i checked you left me standing
in front of enterprise
when i paid for the car and you took off
said [ __ ] i got a badass mexican [ __ ]
she's [ __ ] on you i hope you die
[ __ ] to be talked to like that by my
child's father
and to see this stuff inside the system
i'm like okay they need somebody
somewhere one of us got to be strong one
of us got to step up
and i guess it's gonna have to be me it
might be hard
but it's so worth it i was looking at my
babies the other day like you are so
worth it i am so sorry baby girls like
it make you feel [ __ ] up as a person
after a while
i don't see how a lot of that's why
people say it's just a gateway drug
a lot of people advance to these other
higher drugs because the feelings
i'll be honest it's a [ __ ] up feeling
especially when you really think about
my kids
like damn my kids they're nice to be
here they didn't ask for me as a mom
so you got to kind of
get back on your high horse and be like
hey look i'm going to be mom today
me and friday going back where we came
from
because they don't deserve to be treated
like that
because i was treated like that and i'm
[ __ ] up in my head i got a lot of
mental trauma and i don't want my
daughters to ever have to experience
that we don't have a lot of family
so there's nobody else to take them
their dad's in jail for beating on girls
and stealing cars
mom's over here on drugs about to die at
25 what are they left with
nobody and i won't sell them like that
it's a big challenge but it feels good
to be able to say that
after this whole entire week and all
these little months that i've been
lagging and bullshitting acting like i
don't have kids and i don't have a life
that i should be living
it feels good to say that i'm getting
clean
i'm going to a 90 day program i want my
kids back
they're the biggest part of my life
without them i'm nothing i'm a nobody
i'm empty
my life over been over since high school
once you exit high school
life's over you're just an adult now so
go work you become a modern day slave
and i live i like being my kids modern
day slaves well
you have so much potential megan you
have so much potential i mean of all the
girls on fig that i
i mean you you and just a few others
i've met
had tremendous potential there's not a
lot of the girls i guess they can
use a lifestyle that getting used to it
is it
shouldn't become a custom and a lot of
these girls get used to and i i just
find myself
every time i try to get like these girls
i'm like
oh [ __ ] it i'ma get on there little [ __ ]
it i'm doing what everybody else doing
what is it it's just being lazy and
doing this
as much as they beg for for money why
can't you beg for a job the same way
well i think it's the fast money that
gets it addictive right that part but
the fast money
involves what now you have to be off
drugs because you're up all night trying
to get the fast money
and once the fast money and the drugs
get you fastly in jail
nowhere fast and i got nowhere fast with
a matter of what six months mark how far
we get nowhere fast
we got to a car lot and
maybe to a hotel room to get like a
weekly and that's about it
that's the only place fast i got and i
[ __ ] up
i so i do apologize mark because you are
a good friend and you don't have to help
us
it's a lot of us that are very very
unappreciative because
there's one that just can't stop bugging
me about a mark
and i'm like you don't even want to talk
to mark you just want to see a pocket
ring
oh you did you call mark for me no how
about i call mark for myself and
apologize
and how about i call mark for myself say
hey mark look give me one last chance
help me out look i'm gonna try harder
this time we gonna work smarter not
harder
so this time mark i do apologize you are
a very great friend
and i do want the world to know that
mark is one of the best friends you
could possibly ever have
like for reals like a lot of you don't
get friends like this you don't get
friends that are willing to give the
hard-earned money this man get out here
and he
work hard for everything he has for him
to just easily take it out of his pocket
and be like here you go go [ __ ] it off
on some drugs
if my family knew what i was doing with
people like i mean your daughters would
probably be [ __ ] angry with you
they would be yeah very very like dad i
don't i don't even ask you for that much
my daughter's kind of see it
my uh my family back in chicago probably
would think i'm insane
yeah so they're probably they're
probably looking they're like man what
the [ __ ] has gotten into this guy yeah
that's exactly
as hard as we were getting him to work
no but i mean but but i live my life
how you want to and you know i want to
and i believe that
people like yourself deserve like a
great chance in life
and and you're not getting it and
certainly working fig and
all the drugs and all that and it's not
something i don't choose it's not
something i would choose to do but
when we're in this type of environment
at this point in age it's like you kind
of have to do what you have to do if a
[ __ ] offers the money
of course i'm gonna take it because i
ain't got [ __ ] you guys you guys came
into a
life with maybe some with struggle i
don't i never experienced the silver
spoon i never got to go to disneyland i
didn't go to
six flags i didn't have that fun child
that i had that
what's it like to go take your brother's
toys and go put them on top of a wall
and shoot them down with a bb gun
what's it like to put a trash bag inside
that trash can over there and we fill it
up and we are playing it like it's a
pool we had
a rough i had a rough childhood like
just
we took the little stupidest stuff and
made toys and made it
live made it happy so
the things that these kids have when
they do have good families are like
royalties and they don't understand that
like i look at this because i'm like why
are you [ __ ] up
you come from a good family like that's
a royalty you know that right well he
yells in real time like that's a royalty
bro
like you know having your dad yell at
you is something some of us want and we
can't
yeah you said royalty in the last talk
too and i think i think what you
actually mean is like a luxury
yeah it's like a luxury or however
people may put it
it's something that is special to me in
my eyes
having a parent that's gonna sit there
and yell at you is special that's
something that we don't all get
like i spent my life in juvenile hall
and i'm looking at these girls like bro
i just watched your mom bring you a
whole [ __ ] birthday present to julie
she brought you breakfast bro she came
and visited you you get letters
i think i did a max amount like a year
and some change i didn't receive
one letter the whole time i was there i
didn't get
the oh we love you and why are you fe i
didn't get the why are you effing up
you know serious when you don't even get
that much so when i see kids i [ __ ] up
i'm like
you're a snob you're a little spoiled
[ __ ] because
you have everything that you could
possibly ask for you got good parents
even though they might yell at you but i
would i wish people would have yelled at
me
these days where i get up and i'm like
man why didn't correct me when i was
that young and stupid
like you know me my whole life you
didn't know me since knee high
and you ain't correct me one time you
just sat there and watched me bump my
head a million times
fall backwards and bruise my ass and
it's like a little merry-go-round and
i'm tired to be on this merry-go-round
because it's boring now
it's like i want to experience i want a
passport i want to go get on a plane and
go to [ __ ]
cuba and come back and be like hey look
this is what me and my family did
i can't do that if i'm steady off drugs
all the time every little fifty dollars
i get instead of going to get a room
and washing my ass like every little
fifty dollars he goes oh let's go to the
dope man
and that [ __ ] after a while for some
people i don't know maybe it's just for
myself
that [ __ ] gets tiring and i'm at that
phase where it's like i'm 25 going on 26
i got two kids
and i still don't got [ __ ] to show for i
got a bachelor's degree and an
associate's degree
i still don't have [ __ ] to show for why
because a choice of a drug that just
almost killed me
i mean that that's a smart [ __ ]
you you just almost died you can turn
around and go use drugs right again
right
[ __ ] not even 15 minutes after you're
out the hospital oh yeah where's the
blunt
in the car already
oh that's a problem i said they said do
you want to go to this program
yup take me that's all i know is i want
to go to this program
well what makes you and we want to know
why this is the only way you're going to
get a bet is if you tell us why you want
to do this program
i said because i want my kids why do you
want to be a mom so bad
because it's a life-changing experience
it's awesome it's fun
it's it's live it gets active with my
kids
they do things that i'm like damn you
never know how weird you are until you
have a little you sitting right in front
of you
and i'll be weird to the [ __ ]
cause the [ __ ] my daughters do is like
wow my whole one-year-old had to come
[ __ ] mommy what you doing
i said eating so what you eating
i said pizza she said what tiny pizza
she's one years old having a
full-fledged conversation like
grown-up i said pepper she said oh you
eating petra tony
can i have some mommy look you stay
right there mommy don't move
you stay look at me mommy look look you
stay right there
i said wow i'm getting talked to like
i'm two years old by my two-year-old
like that is a big ordeal in my head so
i like really
look like damn and just
off using drugs you don't realize how
much time
you exceed like all this stuff my
daughter then started walking and
talking and she
wearing pull-ups and got a car and like
whoa where'd this time go you run the
streets i'm running the streets getting
high off drugs and my daughter over here
talking about some mom i got a binions
and you one years old you you look fancy
she look better than me in her little
cars trust me she looked good driving
that thing she said no you move
i said okay ain't gonna touch the car
she said mommy
you want a dollar how my baby offered me
a dollar i can't even offer her a dollar
that's sad and then when you have good
friends like you that are helping us
like we really be [ __ ] it over and
it's like [ __ ]
we don't realize until after the storm
that came through after everything told
up after people like i'm not [ __ ]
with you because you can't stop them
drugs
you can't get off the drugs you won't
get out the streets you lose a lot of
good people like that and
mark's not type person that you want to
lose like that marx wasn't people
with time come or and you really in the
struggle
you ask him sincerely mark going to be
there for you mark a real one
all right i like helping people who are
helping themselves exactly but when
people are kind of just
like here let help me so that i can help
me get high
yeah that's what it turns into that's
what it really is like hey mark help me
with 500
so i could take half that 500 and go get
high off of it the other half i pay for
a room for one day
and the rest of it just gets [ __ ] off
because somebody just stole it no and
then
some of the people have figured out that
they can they can buy it
and then hustle and do things that it's
not cool
like that because i had to caught myself
lying to mark sometimes like
uh [ __ ] you know you who you lying to
right you lie in the mark
this is your only help this is your only
help the only reason why you're even out
still
i should have been in jail if it wasn't
for you mark i'd be in jail
i know i would why because i would have
had no choice but to turn around and
resort to hoeing again
to being a prostitute all over again why
because ain't nobody as generous as mark
later
that's what i do know ain't nobody about
to hand me dollars
i'd be like look run that they gonna be
like here i forty dollar
forty dollar you go forty dollar no no
forty dollar
i need help me no help me forty dollar
no no no no sir sir look you know what
buy
that's the point that i need two of
people the tricks want you to do
something yeah
they want to hear forty dollars really
the low
the lowest amounts for some of the most
beautiful women i'll be rolling up
another stroll like
that i'm not sure what the tricks are
offering out there but
oh they are going to lower but there's
there are some if they can get you
included are some of the most beautiful
women i've ever seen on figaro
really i mean there's about three or
four girls look as good as you though
you know you make that tan look real
good you're sweet but
there are some girls and you would be on
this list who are just like even the
little [ __ ] lady
look at you look at you you're you're
amazing oh the [ __ ] girl
yes the little [ __ ] lady she was out
there like two days ago
and some guy rolled up on her and he's
like i'll give you 800
to pee on me and she's like okay
i'm like wait what did i just see happen
that should be illegal
i mean what we're doing is already
illegal but a [ __ ]
that should be illegal right there is
[ __ ] the
politically correct term for her whoa
for what would be the like i've spoken
to her she said she wants to do an
interview so
she and she's a really nice person but
to see that little itty bitty person
just walk past you and like
bobble her head past and she gets inside
this car and it's like as little as you
are how can you even ever be safe like
you could feel
safe doing what we're doing like i would
feel so scared if i was her and to
actually
i was kind of jealous i didn't go live
mark i was jealous
i said eight hundred dollars [ __ ] i
never got no faith like that
to pee on you the six two girl doesn't
get it but a
small girl man mark i was out there
looking at the way these girls was
hustling i was like this is a whole new
hustle they said the game don't change
it's a damn lie
cause the game changed game to change we
got midgets out there we got
i mean things that i've never seen i've
seen them see
cases like this i've got friends i tell
them you need some rest they say no i
don't need no rest
see you need some rest no i don't need
no rest and i got my friend down here
with me
and she said she didn't need no rest and
she slump dog right now this what
happens when we live in the life
we think we could do something that we
just simply can't
we can't go 78 hours 84 hours
with no sleep it's just not going to
happen and then we get
like this we want to crash i i like to
say like this
you bring crystal naughty is sure to
follow whenever nadia come around know
that it's gonna be some trouble
something gonna get torn down
i've been been in i had nadia slap me
while i was driving
doing like this nadia yeah we call her
nadia who's nadia
when you whenever crystal comes nadia
comes with her
because you know you got to fall out
sometimes
so nadia had me i'm just on the steering
wheel like
this yeah that's what i call nadia
nodding you [ __ ] with crystal
nady is sure to follow and noddy is a
destructive [ __ ]
i don't like nadia so i like to stick
with mary jane even though mary jane
ain't the best girl to be messed with
she's better than crystal and nadia and
crystal and nadia got me nowhere but
broke
homeless and in a jam so it feels good
to actually say that
i'm not on drugs right now good for you
i'm [ __ ] getting healthy i'm getting
my way back
you look better never i mean my kids i
could talk to my kids
i had one of their cousins jealousy she
was like i'm just wondering what are you
doing here like tt first off you've
never had a problem with me
do you ask autry what she's doing here
for the holidays do you ask any other
girl in this family what they're doing
here for the holidays no you don't
so what is your business asking me why
cuz i do drugs because you're a social
worker that likes to lie on my paperwork
and switch
information in the court system oh well
let me be quiet about you because it's
about me
what am i doing here what am i doing
here is i'm here to pick up my mail
and to check on my children a good mom
regardless of what she does is always
gonna check on her kids
and i felt that kick in my ass and i
felt like you know today i'm gonna go
check on my kids
i'ma stop being a bum mom and i'm gonna
go check and see what my girls are doing
see if they pop some fireworks
see how they're eating see how their
health has come to find out my daughter
just got out of the hospital from a
heart problem as well
last week she was in the hospital for
three days
she was having she has a heart murmur so
she was skipping beats and
having a hard time breathing and that
broke me down
so far to where i literally sat and
thought about it like damn making you
really [ __ ] up
like what happens is something happened
to your baby you're so busy inside the
[ __ ] streets doing drugs and playing
with him her and
and kazam that you ain't even know
something happened to your daughter
some of these girls don't care they drop
them off with their moms and mom got em
that's all they know mom got em
but what if mom's not there next week
what if grandma cause my kids are with
their grandmother their grandmother's in
their 60s
i'm like what if grandma isn't there
next week to
to take her to the doctor because
grandma could go at any time
so i gotta be a bigger person and it
feels awesome
all [ __ ] aside not having drugs in
your system
life is so much more fun without the
drugs
like you go to wine testings and have
fun you go do
random ass stupid small [ __ ] walk on the
beach go look at ducks go ride horses
and it's fun but when you're on drugs
nothing is fun
nothing is fun just everything seems
draining and you're always in need
i'm tired of always being in need
because how it looks from the outside
looking another [ __ ]
is not cute a pretty girl but you always
need you always talk about so give me
give me give me
give me guys shot by a [ __ ] named no
yesterday
and [ __ ] give me ain't got back up
because a mark said hell no give me i'm
not giving you nothing
and um with that being realized
realizing that i'm about to lose a real
good friend regardless if it be a money
person or
just a friend that's going to listen to
me and understand me that's not going to
judge me
or make me feel any different than who i
should feel like
it's like damn i lost everything i'm
about to lose that too the only
[ __ ] to actually care enough to
say megan
don't do megan sit you ass down
megan go to school and you don't want to
lose a friend like that because once you
lose that
you do what my friend just did you might
wind up jumping off the bridge my friend
just last week jumped off of a [ __ ]
bridge she said i'm gonna fly down there
and she jumped luckily she is still
alive
she's okay and she's a very beautiful
girl but she's been through a lot
and that's the phase that i caught
myself going to like at the point where
it's like okay i want to [ __ ] go jump
off a [ __ ] bridge i can't see my kids
i have no [ __ ] life i'm young all
everybody sees is pretty pretty pretty
i'm not a slab of meat so all you see is
pretty
well can you see something else people
don't understand
i've been pretty my whole [ __ ] life
pretty is not gonna make any difference
you tell me i'm pretty i'm like cool i
see myself like a regular person
i'm no better than megan the stallion
and i'm no
no less than her nobody is better than
anybody in this world
and to actually have somebody make me
feel like i'm worth it
to tell me i'm beautiful and to be a
friend about it and not be like hey look
i told you you're pretty so give me some
[ __ ]
you know that's awesome feeling so to
almost lose that plus my kids
and almost my life at one time oh i
thought the world was over this week
i said this week is gonna be my final
story
it's over it's over it's hard to believe
how good you look
considering what you just went through
you really look great you look healthy
you know in my chest i'm still getting a
lot of pain in my chest i do have a
contusion
i'm kind of disoriented a little bit but
i think it's just having to get used to
the new medications
well i think whatever whatever that od
or heart attack or whatever it is you
had
scared the [ __ ] out of me nobody but it
your body doesn't recover like that it
takes
no it takes a few days or a week or
whatever it's like
when i wake up i feel like i've been
shocked my whole body and the doctor did
say the same thing you just said it's
gonna take some time
for you know for your body to get
acquainted with these new medications
and i'm like damn
i gotta get acquainted with a heart
medication no it'll probably
you'll probably be back to no medication
and everything will be fine
just the thought of having to do that at
25 is like damn
i'm [ __ ] up bad if i'm falling out of
heart attacks 25
if it's [ __ ] like that really make you
reanalyze your life
and what you want to do and i just got
done telling her
i said why do you want to go i already
finished school
okay don't stop there well megan why do
you tell me but you're
oh well let me let me catch myself i'm
telling you because i see me and you
and you got a lot of potential and
before you get as far
[ __ ] up as i am [ __ ] up i'd rather
try to catch it and put a hold on and
let you know right now
said it right later when you're [ __ ]
up because i'm pretty damn [ __ ] up
people see my face they're like oh
you're like this perfect a1 person you
gotta be rich you gotta have you gotta
have i said no
i like nice things i like looking
appropriate so then if
opportunity it presents itself i can at
least try to take it
even if i'm not the best or stable in my
head i can try
trying is better than just saying [ __ ]
it i give up and that's the point i got
to when i smoked that blunt with that
person
and that [ __ ] it i give up was like damn
[ __ ] you said you give up god said okay
i agree with you
i said uh-uh god uh you weren't supposed
to agree with me
you just agreed to the foolish you
didn't send me into a full-fledged heart
attack at 25 years ago uh-uh
no god you were supposed to disagree
with me but god said you know what this
is what you want you keep asking for it
talk about so i hate my life
you want to die so god agree with me
like here [ __ ] you hate your life so
much here
go on with your bad self and my ass went
right on into that hospital bed and
cried like a little [ __ ]
so it's oh my god i don't know i just
want to come out of here i can't need no
bed no more i look like a big baby i had
all the doctors was coming in there
laughing like
there's a girl in here crying but you
wasn't crying when you had that pipe in
your mouth
you wasn't crying when you were smoking
that weed with drugs in it
i'm looking like well damn i guess
everybody's right i didn't do it nobody
else did it to me but me
and i don't want to do that to me
anymore i want to
maybe one day be an america's next top
model i want to be able to show my
daughters one day in a book like look
look what mommy did
this is accomplishment you know i want
my kids to know what accomplishments are
i don't want my kids to know that oh my
mom said go slap that kid
like that's not cute i'm not trying to
be your homie i'm not trying to be your
friend
i want to be your mom i want to give you
everything that i didn't have and in
order to do that
i have to be better i have to do this
program
i have to complete my 90 days i take my
certificates to the court and i have to
show them i worked hard
and you know what the best feeling in
the world is when you go for something
and in your heart you have self-doubt
and you tell yourself you can't do it
and you turn around and you ace that
[ __ ] and you complete it
and you say damn this the best feeling
in the world
completion accomplishment saying
i did that nobody else did that i did
that now mark did that
i did that that is the best feeling in
the world
and i'm trying to get the best feeling
in the world besides that
we'll be having my daughters in order to
get that i have to go the steps
that a lot of these women are not
willing to take
they want to change we got to start it
somewhere somebody
somebody got to be bold enough to be
like okay i'll do it
and that's how you break the cycle
exactly and i'm trying to break the
cycle i mean the generators start to get
bad
they get stupid or stupider they're
getting reckless and more they're
just like i don't care phase that
everybody wants to go through and i'm
like why
why because a lot of these kids really
come all these girls more than half the
prostitutes you see have very good homes
very very good homes i mean some of
these [ __ ] parents live by you mark
like in good nice areas pretty ass
chandeliers i walk to the home girls i
say well god damn [ __ ] you got a
chandelier
all the crystals and everything in hear
why you sure your mom don't want me to
take my shoes off
she was looking to be like no you could
walk on the carpet i'm looking like are
you sure that looks like some long hair
persian right there
i don't know if you want me to welcome
that with these tennis shoes you know i
want that type of experience
i want to be able to walk into my house
and be like hey [ __ ] it i can get booty
ass naked and walk around my house and
say i did that
because i worked hard for it not because
i went
over there and told that dude over there
like hey empty your pocket
uh-huh you about to get some ass so onto
your pocket that's the most [ __ ] up
feeling in the world to have to go home
to because like now i can't even lay
with the guy that i do want to lay with
because i feel nasty
i feel like damn who's going to want to
lay with me like who's really going to
want to wife a hoe
who's really going to want to say hey
will you marry me knowing damn well your
girl's
out there and she's [ __ ] selling her
body for money
and not even money the littlest money
we're going to call that chump change
she's selling herself a chump change
you think a man's gonna want to lay with
a woman like that no i want to
experience life i want marriage i want a
home i want a foundation
i want to be able to be a cohabitant
partner with somebody to say i can fight
it in this person we did this together
and i'm not gonna get that being a
prostitute i'm not gonna get that being
a drug addict
i'm not gonna get that be no lazy bum
stinking [ __ ] that's just laying around
just to be there
you know i wanna be phil i wanna feel
important i wanna feel more than just
here i want to feel like okay
that's somebody to look at like how
oprah and
and you got vanessa williams all these
ideals
all these people that are big big people
and they're like
they came from the same position as me
halle berry for instance
she came from the mud right on up to
what holly berry the baddest [ __ ] in
the world from what we're here
it's well holly don't want to be like
holly barry i'm trying to be like you
when i grow up
you know i want that feeling of
happiness of real joy and laughter
and i'm willing to take every step
possible to get there
and it doesn't matter if i got to throw
everybody away guess what today world
all y'all gonna get thrown away
everybody got to go in the trash can
why because i want better for me and i
want better for my daughters
that's how you do it i'm 25 and i've
never been to disneyland
it's my it's right right next door to
where i live like
i can't even go to disney i can't afford
disneyland that's sad
nick can't afford a lego lamp can't
afford universal studios right now
should i barely afford the sandwiches i
know it sounds really crazy coming out
of somebody like
you look at me and you're like oh this
this [ __ ] just said she can't afford a
sandwich
yeah you damn right i just said that i
can't afford a [ __ ] sandwich if
it wasn't for mark i wouldn't be
afforded nothing today not even a room
but that's me just being brutally honest
with myself and i guess you got to get
like that sometimes you got to be
brutally honest with yourself
i think that's the only way and it hurts
i ain't gonna lie i'll be beating myself
up some days like man i don't want to
get up
like shoot i get up i might have a
problem with myself today
shoot i might go to the mirror and yell
at myself but i gotta go to the mirror
and say hey you're beautiful
you can do this rock on it's another day
we this is
one more chance to to make it happen
every day god give you as a gift you got
to live it to the fullest
and you gotta abide by the laws of
[ __ ] uncle sam and then you also have
to abide by
being a normal human being a mom a
parent
you could be a father you could be a
mother but
that doesn't mean that you're a father
or a mother you could be a dad there's a
dad and there's a father there's a
mother and there's a mom
a mom put me here a mother raised me
i want my daughters to have that i
didn't get a period talk
i came out the bathroom one day and i
was like oh my god i'm dying
my sister's laughing at me like what are
you talking about i'm like look i'm
dying
i'm showing them my panties and they're
like oh your mom didn't tell you what
period was i'm like no what was period
you know i don't want my daughters to
have to experience that in school with
the little red marks on their little
butts and
you know it's embarrassing and when you
can't teach your kids how to be a proper
a proper little girl it's like damn
where did i steer myself wrong at
all them drugs that [ __ ] crystal and
that [ __ ] nadia over there
coming together they're gonna whoop your
ass every single time i don't care how
much money you got
every single time you gonna get your ass
whooped
every time be halle berry rich and get
your ass what
buy a drug and lose everything because i
look at that dude from uh that's a raven
the eddie kid oh boy that boy didn't
lost every
mmm that boy lost his mind
it sounds really bad cause i shouldn't
be talking about people because i'm
going through it myself
but those are the reasons why i can
actually sit back and look at myself and
be like [ __ ] you do
not want to be that one like because he
went from being this big
cool dude everybody knew from that so
raven eddie eddie eddie that's the one
that raven that chelsea like
and now you look at him cuz he smoked
out ain't got none of his teeth
he wear pants on top of pants that got
sweatpants
he got a bandana up here a bandanna
right here a bandana over here
got a cup with two day old coffee
sliding it
swinging it over here i don't want to be
that one person that ended up like that
everybody say i remember that girl from
high school this is our 40th reunion and
that's her over there remember when all
the boys fought over
that's her right there people going what
looking like shenay from martin i'm not
i don't want to be
that mark i want to be somebody bigger
and better i want to be an inspiration
especially to a lot of these little
girls because some of them don't have
the courage or the will power to say
okay i'm gonna keep trying
including your girls exactly and
i'm their biggest idol yeah
you do not what you say you know i'm
their star like i tell guys
you're your daughter's first love
you're her king without you she's gonna
be
she gonna do what she will do your
daughter probably gonna wind up a hole i
knew it would be i ain't gonna sit here
and lie
brutally honest your daughter probably
will wind up a hoe or
one of them little luguchi mamas at
school wearing long nails and
want to be your friend talk about some
mom i think this boy will you see this
what
i don't think that that's appropriate
and that's a lot of what's going on
these women are being their kids friends
rather than being their moms
and it's kind of like damn i'm looking
at them and i'm looking at myself
i look at my daughters my daughters are
so smart like they're
so smart my daughter taught me how to
pin a screen and i'm like you're one
years old like
how'd you do that and she's like mom mom
mom look mom
she grabbed my chin come here mama look
mom
and show them i said this i'll be damn
this little baby just showed me how to
pin the screen i feel [ __ ] as hell
i don't want my kids teaching me i'm
supposed to be teaching my kids
the kids is making better money than us
nowadays
i had a little boy say hey you come here
he said you got twenty dollars
i said oh well my bad no i got no twenty
dollars for your little ranch yourself
little baby go kick push somewhere
oh you ain't got no money i ain't
talking to you i said well i think we
need some hustle like that in our bones
because these girls will take twenty
dollars and go lay down in an hour leave
i don't want that i'm trying to feel the
ac
i want to go get me an apartment with
some nice couches
and some cable and be like kid get out
my face for a little bit mommy on
moncation
you know it sucks not waking up with
them it sucks not having a life anymore
because trust me i had a three bedroom
house i had three cars
nice yard my daughters had ball pits and
tents and all types of stuff
and i lost it all because i wanted to
smoke
the urge of smoking well maybe what
happened to you this week
might be the best thing that ever
happened to you yeah what happened to me
this week even though it was the
scariest thing and it's not anything
anybody should
have to experience at 25 that heart
attack was
hands down the best thing that happened
to me this week even though it was the
worst it was the best
because if it wasn't for that heart
attack my eyes would still probably be
down on uh
what's that 121st and fig
chilling at the big old edge oh doing
nothingness with my life sitting in the
corner
looking at the homie cell drugs there's
nothing good that happens today there's
nothing
that will tell us there's nothing good
well it is the same homies
my my friend said you leave your hood
for one year and you come back
them ten broke [ __ ] you seen from that
corner gonna be the same ten broke
[ __ ] you see on the corner when you
come back
now if you walk your ass over there and
you sit with him that makes you what
the 11th broke dumbass [ __ ] that then
went over there and sat there
i don't want to be that 11 dumb broke
ass [ __ ] i'm trying to be that 11
rich ass [ __ ] i'm trying to be a
protege i'm trying to be somebody that
woke up and did something i don't went
from dirt to [ __ ] i got a couple
stacks
i might only got a little four thousand
dollars in my bank account but it's
something more than nothing
and [ __ ] my nothing is eating at me
like
i'm tired of getting ate out by nothing
cause i get hungry
i'm a human i want to sleep i want to go
take a shower i want nice clothes
i want to see what it's like to put on
some nice jewelry that's real jewelry
but most of all i want my daughters that
is the best part of my life and i can't
live without them
so i'm gonna go do this program and i'm
about to show the whole world
[ __ ] megan can when my dad said we're
mexicans not mexicans so i'm gonna make
it happen
because i got two little people watching
me and then little people was depending
on me to be
better than my mom was to actually be
there
you know i think about how my daughters
feel when they wake up in the mornings
and it breaks my heart like damn i
wonder if my daughters are
smart enough to know like okay i'm
waking up and i'm looking for my mom but
she's not there
i want to be there every single step
from here on now
i don't know what my daughter's like
right now because last time i see she
was in car seat
and it's [ __ ] up because i feel like i
missed so much already like
not getting to see her going through the
first talking phase or her first steps
it should make any mom want to wake up
and get off drugs
because when you look back and you see
your kids and how beautiful they are
it's like wow
i made them i did that but an even
better feeling to say i
taught them that i showed them how to be
women
i showed them how to say no to drugs
willpower it's not what you can give
your child at all
it's never been that it's the time and
the consistency
because if i could replace my jordans
with my father's time
or my mom's time i would replace every
[ __ ] pair of shoes i got in my closet
just for that little bit of time that's
how valuable it is
and with that being said i'm about to go
real world
and knock out this 90 day program for my
girls i'm proud of you
and hopefully do another interview and
come back a little bit chunkier and a
little bit better i might have a
ponytail next time you see me you know
my hair grown back
i'm going through the phases of life and
i went through the
i'm chopping my hair off face my hair
was to my butt like all my real hair
at my ass i [ __ ] one day i don't know
what the hell got into me but i
grabbed my ponytail i was like going
through
some trauma within myself i want me back
i want to feel grounded i want to feel
okay
i want to be a mom all over again
because that's the best thing that ever
happened to me was having my daughters
and if it wasn't for them quite frankly
i'd probably be dead
all bs aside because i was prostituting
big in las vegas and
my first daughter was born in las vegas
and that's around the time a lot of
these girls were coming up in body bags
stuffed inside the drains
and you know coming up missing found
behind the hotel on the train tracks
i would really probably be dead because
i was this close
to a man killing me trying to go get
them a couple of dollars not for them
not for my little feet but for him that
same hymn that turned around and ran me
over on my 21st birthday
the same hymn that broke my jaw the same
hymn that said [ __ ] i wish you die
the same him that said [ __ ] i got a
badass mess can [ __ ] she's [ __ ]
on you you're in [ __ ] you're never gonna
have [ __ ] and you'll never be [ __ ]
what do you think keeps so many girls
with their pimps they
it's not that
they love them a lot of times it's that
they scare us
they'll scare you into they'll because
as many times as they've put their hands
on you
you already know okay what's coming when
he's angry
so you already bracing yourself prepared
and it's
he scares me that much to where i will
stay with the [ __ ] that's
hurting me
because i'm that scared to leave because
i don't know what he'll do if i leave
is he gonna follow me down that street
just like what happened on my 24th
birthday
i tried to tell him i didn't do anything
to you
you left me for somebody else and you're
mad at me he ran me over
so imagine what it is if you're their
money
and they're only money and you turn
around and try to walk away
it's the scare the what am i gonna do if
i turn around is he gonna hit me
if i turn around am i gonna get a gun
put to the back of my head
if i turn around will i be breathing in
five seconds
it's the the force
and that alpha that that we run it all
but i look at it like this [ __ ] am i
paying you for because you sat in the
car and looked at me through the car
window you could have ten dollars
how about that that's what i mean pimps
nowadays these are the weakest pimps
i've ever seen
y'all pimping for a sack of some [ __ ]
cocaine in what a room for one night
that you're not even with your woman
you're in there with five other guys at
that
so it's just everything nowadays in the
game it just looks bad and i i'm tired
of it i'm tired of living the life i'm
tired of being in the game i'm tired of
hustling
i'm tired of struggling for the next
meal i'm tired of struggling for
diapers and how i'm gonna send the kids
this and how about it's time to struggle
the right way
because when you work hard for it the
[ __ ]
the reward at the end of the tunnel is
so much better
i swear to god it is because i've worked
and i've gotten there before
and when i got there i [ __ ] up and i
started doing drugs because i thought
hey i'm here i did it i already made it
you know i got the money i got the truck
i got the house i got everything going
on
but you're not supposed to stop once you
get there you're supposed to keep going
and i should have took that from what
your life is mark you kept going you
didn't stop because hey i got one
interview
hey i took one picture hey i got one
friend that's rich
you kept going and striving you got kids
and i realized that now like okay these
kids
ain't gonna stop growing these little
people gonna keep getting bigger and
bigger and bigger my little me's
and that means that i can't stop either
that means that i'm going to push
every day i love construction i do
construction most guys are like oh you
do struggle yeah i do construction i
build houses
i knock houses down i paint i know how
to do stucco pavement
electrical plumbing you name it i'll
bust down i haven't come work on your
car
but it's wanting to put the power and
the effort behind it
and a lot of us are very talented women
you have a lot of talented women out
here working these streets
but people see us as street workers so
they don't want to give us the
opportunity
so the women don't want to try hard
enough to at least change
because the first thing they see is oh
you're a prostitute
oh we can't we can't let you work here
you're a prostitute
you know and it's not gonna change
unless we as women get up and start to
change that
whole ordeal i mean the county
everything's [ __ ] free right now how
could you not
change like i don't understand how
people are broke right now everybody's
getting edd but everybody's broke
how are you broke y'all getting
thousands of dollars i don't get edd
i don't get the stimulus checks i don't
get none of that i don't even get county
i don't get food stamps i don't get
nothing everything comes out of my
pocket literally
and that is the hardest thing to do in
life is pay for everything out of pocket
i
swear if i get county and all that free
[ __ ] i so would
but because the jobs that i've worked
before stops me from receiving the
benefits now
but the outcome at the end is so awesome
you might be beat and toe up fingernails
toe back looking like who did it and why
but the feeling you could get when you
lay on your couch dirty as [ __ ]
pain on your face toes stinking
is like wow this is a great feeling i
just worked my ass off
and i did something that nobody else did
and it was productive
same way you could go tag on the wall
and go to jail
the same way you go find you a [ __ ]
piece of cardboard laminate it
take that little piece of art and go up
to venice and sell it people buy [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ] at venice all the time so
why not take that art form and be
productive
rather than be destructive i had to
learn the hard way and
that heart attack taught me so i'm going
to be bigger and better this week
starting tomorrow at 9am i am going to
become a different person you guys will
see
this whole transformation in about 90
let's get 95 days
i got to give it a little extra time on
the end you know got to prep myself when
i come back i got to come back correct
but i'm going away for 90 days hopefully
mark will have another interview ready
for me
and you guys will see 90 days into what
a transformation from a street mom
a prostitute a hustler a whatever you
want to call it
because people have different names
jezebels whatever you want to call them
everybody has a different name but you
will literally see the transformation
and the happiness within somebody within
me
i'm gonna use myself for the perfect
example for everybody
first time you guys see my interview my
face was more so like
right now i'm like smiling i'm happy i'm
like [ __ ] [ __ ]
life i'm living it you know and it's
awesome feeling like there's no drugs it
feels good to say there's no drugs
finally
like it feels good to be able to go to
sleep and wake up like bro
staying up all night is not fun you'll
be worn and torn by the morning time
so my 90 day challenge
and this y'all 90 days to sit here and
sulk and think
like damn what is megan go come back out
this program looking like
what is her going to be what's going to
be her new attitude what's she going to
be doing in this 90 days
where will megan have gotten and i'm
going to come back and i'll be like look
i got this certificate i got that
certificate i got my kids i'm working on
a house
i'm working on another car i have goals
and i'm going to meet them
it's not there's no question it's i'm
gonna do it period
and for everybody that said that i
couldn't do it
this is me saying that i'm gonna do it
and you guys can literally physically
see somebody that wants you to see them
be a transformation because at the end
of the day
just this one interview could change a
lot of lives
because i want to change i can make
somebody else want to change
because the positivity and the strive
that i'm gonna have behind this i got
too much tenacity a lot of these women
got
too much tenacity too much drive too
much smarts but it's like
somebody has to push them mark pushed me
that's what mark you're a big reason
why i'm wanting to do the program to go
get better i'm like damn [ __ ] i just
lost the only friend i [ __ ] got
everybody else just want to use me up
want to abuse me want to think i'm a
slab of meat oh you pretty can i get a
[ __ ]
like no you can't pretty [ __ ] it
you're like a big influence on my life
mark
like to actually get up and want to do
something better with myself
and it took for me to meet this whole
person that i'm like where did you just
fall out of the sky from mark like
you're just a super-sized giant white
guy
and i never seen a super-sized giant
white guy before but you're like
awesome you're different and you want to
help us like why are you wanting to help
us
people from the hood and when you
reanalyze yourself you're like damn
there are people that do have money that
are
willing to help us but we want we have
to want the help and i want the help and
i'm going to show you what getting the
help
does after 90 days in a program
wanting to get your life back together
because i want my life back
i don't know about anybody else but
speaking for myself i want my life back
i want my kids back i want happiness
i want joy and laughter and i'm gonna
get that starting this week
i can't wait so i will see you all 90
days see you in the fall
yes we make peace in our chicken grease
we trying to how they say elevate
i only want people in my life that want
to elevate
and i want to elevate so for everybody
that does know megan
everybody that see me before walking the
streets at a store at a walmart
hi hello you said i couldn't i'm saying
i can
90 day transformation and i see your
[ __ ] soon
shoot they're going to be it's time baby
it's time baby i'm so proud of you
you're awesome you're amazing you are
like this without you i think i might
have been
jumping off a bridge by themselves